you
no I wanna I wanna maybe whatever see
form change it up a little bit okay um
let's try night if three maybe we go
cattle and land
now let's go III
play something strong here what time is
it okay
all right
let's uh let's ask him one little
question
who
the bishop pair he's not the happiest
bishop around
I actually have some experience with
this structure
I've played several games with this
structure I'm forgetting
forgetting the exact arrangement I
normally go with
okay that's that makes sense because
giving up b5 it's an issue
okay let's start with Bishop here
this is my super piece
light-square bishop well actually maybe
no I don't know
let's start with here
probably have to castle let's do it
court grip going on in the Kings side
and
you
what is the way forward
with this
clearly I'm lining up before and clearly
that is prevented
I'm prepared to run back home with my
queen
maybe there's g3
bishop recycle
I'm gonna do this now they're preparing
to jump in and I want to be able to take
with the night and not end up in a fork
so that's why I want my queen out of
that if they try this kind of cave
mannish stuff I think I'm okay so here's
my opportunity to take him out so now
this frees up my rook and Bishop to see
the world bishop where do you belong
I'm gonna say here my queen might want
to sneak out in this direction at some
point so let's not go to e2 all so this
will be a nice structure g3 Bishop on g2
how do i how do i open this up
successfully though their knight is
gonna be enormous here I may have to
return here just to take them out if I
do this this is annoying if I do this
this is annoying huh what do I do
let's make a move yeah make a move any
move okay now yeah I have to challenge
you should I've done that no here I'll
go here
I'd like to see this pawn can seapunk
convert into a deep on so my rook has
some more options
he has a responsibility
pressure here my queen can maybe sneak
out and provoke some weaknesses I don't
know he should probably return
if the night goes back maybe I just
sneak in a three I don't know
alright let's just make a quick move
it's a very slow position yeah
let's just return
here I'll probably do this again
back and forth miss back and forth and
this alright let's let's attempt
something like no that's no good here
takes here b5 in my rook is dead okay
this ID is no good although right now
I'm turning upon wait a second
I'm winning upon I didn't see that
that's a look what I found move I love
those
I could fend off these mates
master defender gonna try this stuff
mm-hmm I'm telling you though my bishop
is a master defender let's let's free up
my queen from babysitting the rook and
next up actually we're just gonna flush
the Queen away
go somewhere else
get off of this diagonal you're not
welcome you are not welcome here anymore
uh-huh okay let's go here I don't want
to do this because I give up too good of
a square he's probably going to go here
we're baby step in it
baby steps
you
I guess here to offset the night
um but I could take care now
King f1
it looks scary but I don't know what the
follow-up is what's the Queen is here
let's return mm-hmm my time
you
it is extra scary Myrick isn't playing
the rook is going to be playing very
soon can I get the G for a square
let's do it
clean check here I'm in a pin but I have
this covered
bishop here
clean there
did not consider that mouth
yikes I'm busted here
rook takes pawn got a defend here this
should be promoting somehow no why did I
let my King move up I'm untangling
they should not take my rook they took
my rook
you
I am playing this in a very foolish way
my king over here
stop the night and threaten this
kill the night
could I have taken the bishop I don't
know
this is such poor techne
what I'm doing here awful
let's run with him
you
you
[Music]
yikes
oh I totally missed that move
man
I'm a goner
you
man
felt like I could have converted that
you
they're in a pin the knight is pinned
you
oh man
you
lucky to get away with the draw here
very lucky
you
okay and I I was I was losing I was
winning but such terrible technique
there I don't know why I didn't pick
that Jeep on up like last week oh my god
I let their King get all the way down to
h4 I don't know
I don't have words to describe that whoa
what just happened there
you